واشنطن تلاحق طهران في مياه الخليج
الولايات المتحده تستعد لمواجهه تهديده
ايران في المنطقه
قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه الجنرال
مايكل كورولا اعلن ان قوه مخصصه للانظمه
غير الماهوله في الخليج ستنشر اكثر من 100
سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه
بحلول العام المقبل فاطلاق القوه 59 في
مياه الخليج يهدف للتعامل مع تهديده ايران
من خلال تطوير برنامج تكنولوجيا مع شركاء
الولايات المتحده للتصدي لخطر المسير
الايراني يقول المسؤول الامريكي مشيرا الى
ان نشر هذه القوه ياتي بهدف الدمج بين
السفن المسيره والذكاء الاصطناعي
القوه 59 تم اطلاقها في سبتمبر من العام
الماضي في البحرين مقر الاسطول الخامس
بهدف دمج الانظمه غير الماهوله هو ذكاء
الاصطناعي في عمليات الشرق الاوسط بعد
سلسله هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار ضد السفن
والقي باللوم فيها على ايران تقارير صحفيه
امريكيه سبق ان تحدثت عن عمل البحريه
الامريكيه مع دول في الشرق الاوسط لاطلاق
شبكه من الطائره المسيره لمواجهه
التهديدات العسكريه الايرانيه من خلال
ارسال هذه الطائرات معلوماتها الى الاسطول
الخامس
الامريكيه ما سيمكن من مراقبه اكبر في
مياه المنطقه هي خطوه جديده من واشنطن في
محاوله للتغلب على المسيرده الايرانيه
التي تعتبرها الولايات المتحده تهديدا
تكنولوجيا للامن الاقليمي خاصه بعد كم
الدمار الذي الحقته روسيا بنيه طاقه
الاوكرانيه باستخدام المسيرات الايرانيه
بلال البوجداني العربيه